hey guys Ryan right here then sever here
in 60 frames per second we are gonna
watch all fatalities and x-ray so far
for Mortal Kombat X so let's check this
out
PS I will be playing on dance channel
Mortal Kombat X we're gonna punch each
other can't remember all these that was
Oh boobs yeah and your face oh the
tongue pretty common the details are
[Music]
but sit in the mouth oh my god do you
know this time was spent on their
goddamn organs
[Music]
that was a bad food but I don't pee
she's the one to really like Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
and
[Music]
x-rays no no no it's not doing well for
you not good for my brain
[Music]
these people fight after getting their
[__] like neck rope that how do you
have you how do you even how do we even
afterwards man
[Music]
[Applause]
you're right you want to take ready Kim
pray this is like what a 700 tower
fatalities
I feel myself uncomfortable fatality
bonus
what's with the chopping of the face man
that's the one that most yeah well it's
over it's over
holy [__] it's quite an adventure people
that out there I went back and forth
from o2 I wasn't that bad oh my god I
think I'm gonna be sick too oh yeah I'll
just you were gonna bother I guess I'm
getting used to this dad
you'd like looked at me at one point I
was like he's gonna bomb it on I went
through a whole character arc we just
went through Lord of the Rings there's
something else oh [__] I can't get those
noises out of my head okay bone breaking
noises just it's always like I only got
one thing to say yes I'm so [__] when
you're playing someone like it when
you're like [__] them up and you're
doing that crazy [__] to them it's
probably gonna it's gonna be a great
game for a like a party - yeah but like
watching all of those that are oh so
[__] the dirts yeah I am a little
much I I now understand why everyone
wanted I've never been nauseous the only
thing that got me nauseous before was
saw seven that movie got me nauseous
yeah this is the first video game where
I'm like huh I feel something coming up
alright the amount of detail in like
yeah
but there is a lot of detail to the
violence man kind of impressive no it's
it's stunningly yes like this is the
sort of technology that like if they
finished making Mortal Kombat and then
they hand like the models and everything
to like medical yeah kidding like yeah
we got this technology from Mortal
Kombat so you see here this is the part
of your brain I hope well anyway guys
thanks for mentioning that was out
thanks if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects dan
has a gaming channel gameplays and such
like I said earlier I'm gonna be on
there from Mortal Kombat X so keep a
lookout for that peeps you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
it is so much fun because Dan is posting
pictures of his nips all the time so
then weren't true I'd be dead he has a
purple shirt with a nipple purple nurple
don't you do it yourself I do it to
myself what yeah